varios países fronterizos y cercanos a
afganistán temen una nueva oleada de
personas que están intentando huir de la
situación en su país que podemos esperar
de esta situación y como debería
reaccionar la comunidad internacional
bueno muchas gracias a ustedes por la
invitación
evidentemente hasta hace pocos días la
frontera de chamán del justo con
pakistán había estado cerrada para
evitar esta situación de el desborde de
las personas tratando de buscar refugio
en otros países el país que siempre se
ha visto más afectado por este tipo de
situaciones cuando se trata de
afganistán es sin lugar a dudas pakistán
entonces y en pakistán la segunda
problemática se deriva sin satanizar la
migración de los problemas de seguridad
que trae esta situación sobre todo en el
conflicto en las infiltraciones que hay
por momentos en el caso de la india
entonces por ahora la situación más
difícil en cuanto a refugiados la va a
vivir pakistán la segunda situación en
cuanto a temas de migrantes no hay que
olvidar que el gran población de las
ciudades que venía conquistando y
retomando los talibán se había refugiado
en kabul
entonces estos también saldrán a oír a
otros a otros territorios y que supone
para las mujeres de afganistán la vuelta
del talibán al frente del país creo que
esta es la mayor preocupación digamos
las dos principales preocupaciones en
este momento es evidente que los talibán
ya entraron a la capital los capiteles
ya tienen el control de más de 34
provincias
por lo cual la pregunta es va a haber un
traspaso completo de poder o va a haber
una transición yo creo que va a ser la
primera el traspaso al poder y de ahí la
pregunta es van a establecer de acuerdo
al código past igual y ya su visión de
la isla nuevamente qué es lo que se
espera un control extremo y una visión
supremamente radical del islam que deja
las mujeres prácticamente sin derechos
entonces creo que estaríamos frente al
retorno de lo que vivimos entre el 96 y
el 2001 en temas de derechos de la mujer